[MUSIC PLAY]
ROK ZORKO: I'm Dress Zorko.
I am the vice president of products.
When we started, there were only eight of us.
Everything was sketched on a whiteboard
and then built very quickly.
In the first six months we built something like seven or eight programs, I think.
And the last one, Talking Tom, was then a global hit.
IZA LOGIN: Currently we have more than 2.5
billion downloads and over 250 million monthly users
just on the Talking Tom and Friends franchise,
and we are all eager to go on like this.
ROK ZORKO: We've seen Android become our majority platform.
When we launched My Talking Tom in November 2013,
the initial figures were 50/50.
That means 50% of our users and downloads came from Android and 50
from other platforms.
Now the split is 70/30.
That means 70% Android, 30% other platforms,
but we use the same cross marketing.
We use the same marketing, so it just means
that Android has grown.
Outfit7's launch strategy for the latest games
has always been all platforms at the same time.
And the main reason is that you're the biggest
impact, and we really don't want to
any of our users should be dissatisfied.
MARKO STAMCAR: We have My Talking Angela in December
launched.
We first performed phase deployment in Google Play
and then, after everything was ready,
has gone 100% on all platforms.
And within 1 week, I think, we had 1 million downloads.
So it was a great success and recognition for all our teams,
from products to marketing.
ROK ZORKO: We only delivered paid programs,
and now we do free (freemium) programs within our purchases
from 2013 and 2014, and revenue growth was more than 1,000%.
I think we have chosen the right strategy to go "freemium".
When we built our first program, AdMob was the only software provider
inside. It is still one of our most important advertising providers.
We didn't really expect us to earn so much.
Our most successful programs right now have everyone
a lot of mini games inside them, and us
has decided that the best way to bring engagement to a new level is
is to put Google Play Services rankings in
and it really encourages competition in a healthy way.
I think the main reason why our downloads continue to grow faster,
is because we have always been very good at cross marketing.
We always say internally that 50% of our business is
to build great apps and games
And the other 50% is making sure people are aware of them.
MARKO STAMCAR: When we got so successful with apps,
wanted us to have Outfit7 had to become more than just a program company.
We wanted to be a company that provides entertainment.
That's why we started building our YouTube channel
And now we have millions of subscribers
and 1.4 billion viewers.
And we were recently accepted for YouTube for Children
program.
IZA LOGIN: Google plays a big role because in some
areas we could not imagine it without Google
do our distribution, and it's nice to see how users
play with and enjoy our programs worldwide.